Donald Trump has been found liable for
sexual assault and defamation and as a
result Eugene Carroll has been awarded 5
million dollars in Damages now note that
no one here has been convicted this was
a civil suit not a Criminal suit so no
one's guilty of anything but Donald
Trump is liable for five million dollars
So today we're going to talk about how
we got here and what happened at the E.G
Carroll trial now agent Carroll says
that Donald Trump sexually assaulted her
in 1995 or 1996 at the Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in Manhattan at the
time Carol was a TV talk show
personality who also wrote an advice
column Carol and Trump may have been
acquainted with each other the photo and
the complaint shows the two of them
together at a party during the same era
however Trump denies knowing who Carol
was despite the photo now Carol said she
ran into Trump when he was shopping for
a gift for an unnamed girl according to
the Carol complaint she helped him shop
showing him Handbags and hats Trump
rejected those ideas and steered Carol
upstairs to the lingerie section where
he allegedly grabbed a body suit and
asked Carol to try it on she says that
she told him to try it on himself and
Carol claims that Trump pushed her into
a dressing room forced her up against a
dressing room wall pinned her in place
with his shoulder and raped her after
the incident Carol claims that she
immediately called a friend and relayed
what happened to her and also claims
that a few days later she confided in a
second friend apparently fearing for her
reputation in her career Carol decided
not to report the rape to police she
believed that if she publicly accused
Trump of rape he wouldn't face serious
consequences while her life would be put
on trial fast forward to 2016 when Trump
was elected president Carroll quote
watched as a throng of women came
forward and accused Trump of sexual
assault only to be denigrated and then
brushed aside Carol says that seeing
Harvey Weinstein finally faced the music
for the history of assault I convinced
her to go public Carol decided to write
a book about her experiences with men
including Trump entitled what do we need
men for a modest proposal which was
published in July of 2019. now obviously
Trump has publicly denied assaulting
Carol in three separate statements
saying he'd never met Carol she was ugly
and she was not his type he also
asserted that she had no Witnesses and
in response to Trump's statements two of
Carol's friends came forward to
corroborate her assertion that she told
them about the rape shortly after it
happened now harassment and abuse are
real problems that can happen to anyone
and now my Law Firm the eagle team can
help if you've been the victim of sexual
harassment or abuse in the past and it's
not just that we can help with almost
any injury of any kind an auto accident
a medical malpractice workers
compensation the link to our page is
down in the description we're here to
listen and help now in November 2019
Carol sued Trump for defamation in his
personal capacity in New York State
Court Trump was still the president and
he defended the case on the basis that
he had absolute immunity from civil
lawsuits as such now the scope of
presidential immunity has only been
tested a handful of times in the 1982
case Nixon vs Fitzgerald the Supreme
Court rule that the president has
brought immunity from lawsuits for
official acts undertaken while as
president 15 years later in Clinton
versus Jones the Supreme Court held that
the president does not have absolute
immunity from civil litigation
surrounding acts that were not part of
his official duties now Trump's justice
department and eventually Joe Biden's
justice department intervened in the
case to defended Trump arguing that
unlike Bill Clinton Trump had immunity
because the comments he made about Carol
were made in his personal capacity as
president so why would the two cases be
treated differently well Paula Jones's
lawsuit against Clinton was for sexual
harassment that happened before he was
president whereas Carol's lawsuit is
about statements Trump made while he was
the sitting president even though the
acts themselves might have happened
earlier now it would have been so easy
for Trump to escape liability in the
Carol matter if he had just stopped
talking about her after he had become a
private citizen but alas stop talking is
not an instruction that Trump will ever
follow as dozens of lawyers can attest
and so in October of 2022 Trump went on
Truth social to rant and Rave about
Carol in his extremely long statement he
said quote this Miss Bergdorf Goodman
case is a complete con job I don't know
this woman have no idea who she is other
than it seems she got a picture of me
many years ago with her husband shaking
my hand on a reception line in a
celebrity charity event she has no idea
what day what week what month what year
or what decade the so-called event
supposedly took place the reason she she
doesn't know is because it never
happened and she doesn't want to get
caught up with details or facts that can
be proven wrong now Trump's truth social
statement was covered by hundreds of
newspapers and exhaustively enumerated
in this footnote which is more like a
yard note am I right yeah we'll try and
find humor wherever we can here
um but uh congratulations Mr President
you just bought yourself another
defamation lawsuit because you re-upped
the same comments after you were
president as a result Carol sued him for
common law defamation based on allegedly
false and defamatory statements he made
on October 12 2022 and she also sued him
for common law battery and on April 25th
a jury was selected and the trial kicked
off so what happened during this trial
well Carol gave a testimony about what
she says happened Trump's opposition was
also played in court although he did not
attend and a significant part of the
trial has been three women explaining
why they didn't call the police on the
then Real Estate Mogul Donald Trump
Carol said she didn't go to the police
because women of her generation were
trained to be silent if a man attacked
them Trump's lawyer countered that Carol
once called the police on a group of of
children who attacked her mailbox on
Halloween suggesting that she would have
called the cops on Trump if it had
really happened Carol's friend Lisa
bernbach backed up Carol's assertion
that she did call bernbach right after
the alleged attack and burbach said that
the Carol was emotional and
hyperventilating on the call and next up
was Jessica Leeds whose first encounter
with Trump was when he allegedly
assaulted her for the complaint Trump
attacked leads on a plane when she was
bumped to a first class seat next to him
Leeds testified the quote there was no
conversation it was like out of the blue
it was like a tussle he was trying to
kiss me trying to pull me towards him he
was grabbing my breasts it was like he
had 40 zillion hands Natasha stoinoff of
former journalist for People magazine
broken in tears when she was shown the
Access Hollywood tape she said that she
was stunned and speechless when Trump
attacked her which happened when she
went to Mar-A-Lago to interview Trump
stornov says that she didn't report what
had happened because she was afraid it
would hurt her career the jury also
heard from Robert Salerno in ex Bergdorf
Goodman executive who testified that he
didn't think that there were security
camera cameras on the sixth floor during
the 1990s when Trump's lawyers
questioned whether the dressing room
doors would have been unlocked Salerno
said a lot of the time the doors were
not locked they kept them open or they
propped them open then we'll get to
Trump's defense or lack thereof in just
a second but there were so many
interesting legal issues here that had a
huge effect on trial before the trial
there was a question of the
admissibility of the axis Hollywood tape
Trump's lawyer Elena Haba argued that
the conduct Trump described in the video
isn't at all like the violent rape that
Carol described and in the judge's order
analyzing this type of propensity
evidence he stressed that there are
various ways that a reasonable person
could interpret Trump's Access Hollywood
statements they could assume he's just a
braggard making up stories or that he
was talking about what other stars did
to women alternatively a person could
believe that Trump grabs women but you
know what whether they consent or not
well historically that's true with stars
true with stars that they can grab women
but well that's what it's if you look
over the last million years I guess
that's been largely true not always but
largely true
unfortunately or fortunately
and you consider yourself to be a star
I think you can say that yeah
now ultimately judge Kaplan ruled that
the jurors could reasonably conclude
based on the tape alone that Trump quote
in fact has had contact with women's
genitalia in the past without their
consent or that he has attempted to do
so so this meant that the jury would
hear the axis Hollywood tape in trial
and would decide for themselves whether
it indicated that Trump routinely
touches women in their intimate areas
with or puts out their consent now
Donald Trump made the unusual decision
not to put on a defense the only two
witnesses on Trump's witness list were
Trump himself and the psychiatrist but
neither testified in court now that
doesn't mean he was conceding liability
his lawyers cross-examined all the
plaintiff's Witnesses and the plaintiff
Eugene Carroll has the burden of proof
in this case though as we'll talk about
the burden of proof in a civil case is
very very different from the burden of
proof in a criminal case Trump's lawyer
Joe takapina questioned why Carol didn't
scream she said quote I'm telling you he
raped me whether I screamed or not I
don't need an excuse for not screaming
and stoinoff testified that she also
didn't scream and in addition to
asserting that the assault never
happened takapina argue that the lawsuit
was part of a vast conspiracy against
Trump and judge Kaplan allowed the
defense to question Carol on why she
decided to file a lawsuit eliciting
testimony that she got the idea to sue
from never Trump lawyer George Conway
kellyanne's uh former better half and
Conway introduced Carol to her now
lawyer Robbie Kaplan and takabina tried
to find inconsistencies in Carol's
statements takapina offered an audio
clip of an interview where Carol said
that she didn't blame Trump for her
failure to have another relationship
quote I think it wasn't because of him I
think it was I just didn't have the luck
to meet the person that would cause me
to be desirous again I think maybe in
that dressing room my desire for desire
was killed Carol also admitted that she
was a massive fan of The Apprentice
which might have been at odds with a
recession that the alleged assault
damaged her takapina showed a jury a
2012 Facebook post where Carol jokes
about whether she would have sex with
Donald Trump for seventeen thousand
dollars and that whether any of that
actually amounts to an inconsistency is
up for the jury to decide but in a civil
case like this the plaintiff has the
burden of roof but the burden of proof
is not Beyond reasonable doubt it is a
preponderance of the evidence which is
basically more likely than not or 51
compared to 49 it's only showing that
your story is more believable than the
other sides so the burden is lower but
still the plaintiff does have the burden
here so Trump's lack of defense is less
strange than it might seem on its face
after all his claim is that what EG and
Carol is claiming is not true and if he
had the burden of proof he'd be trying
to prove a negative he just simply needs
to say that it's more likely that it's
not true than it is true now I also
mentioned some propensity evidence which
is fairly unusual in a case like this
there were two women that testified that
Trump assaulted them in the same way
that he allegedly assaulted Carol
Natasha stoinoff and Jessica Leeds now
there was a huge battle over the
admissibility of this propensity
evidence before trial even got underway
now propensity evidence is evidence of
one crime that is used to show the
defendant is more likely to have
committed another crime now there is
generally a bar against using propensity
evidence or character evidence to prove
that the defendant committed crime or a
civil tort now if someone committed a
crime in the past they are probably more
likely
to have committed the crime at issue but
the courts believe that it's too easy to
draw the conclusion there and that you
really need to prove a crime actually
happened in the specific instance
without being able to show that they
just have a character for doing so and
in fact Federal rule of evidence 404
States in part they quote evidence of a
person's character trait or trait of
character is not admissible for the
purpose of proving action in Conformity
they're with on a particular occasion
now rule 404 exists because juries tend
to overvalue character evidence when we
don't want to find a person guilty or
liable just because they had committed a
prior bad act however Federal rule of
evidence 415 removes the character
evidence bar for sexual assault cases
probably because it's a recognition of
how hard it can be to prove a case in a
he said she said case that rule states
quote in a civil case involving a claim
for Relief Based On A party's alleged
sexual assault or child molestation the
court May admit evidence that the party
committed any other sexual assault or
child molestation so how do we Square
rule 404 with rule 4 15 well when a
victim comes forward with allegations of
sexual assault juries tend to minimize
the victim's story unless there is
evidence that a defendant did it to
someone else and Rule 415 is supposed to
level the playing field for victims of
sexual assault Trump's lawyers file a
motion to exclude the leads and stoyanov
testimony on the basis that whatever it
is that Trump did to them it wouldn't
qualify sexual assault and therefore
couldn't be admissible under rule 415
but on March 15th the judge ruled that
if true the allegations by both women
would qualify as a type of sexual
assault and their testimony would
therefore be admissible Trump then
brought in Joe takapina as his trial
lawyer takapina has previously defended
Michael Jackson Alex Rodriguez and Meek
Mill attacking peanut filed a motion on
the eve of trial attempting to
relitigate the admissibility of
stoyanov's testimony now judges hate
relitigating the same thing that they've
already ruled on and this second
argument went over like a lead balloon
judge Kaplan denied the attacking
emotion writing the motion was not just
untimely but also the attack failed to
show that the Court's original decision
overlooked matters or controlling
decisions so what did Carol have to
prove in this case well judge Kaplan
ruled that Carol's defamation claim was
for libel per se all that meant is that
in a defamation per se case a plaintiff
doesn't need to prove damages at the
outset they were initially presumed and
Carol had to prove that Trump's
statements were untrue and that they
harmed her reputation and profession
we've covered this a lot on this channel
Carol had to show that Trump's
statements had a tendency to expose her
to public hatred contempt ridicule or
disgrace and she had to prove that when
Trump denied knowing her and denied
sexually abusing her that he knew it was
false or acted with Reckless disregard
for the truth or falsity of that
statement and in a way Carol's civil
battery claim was easier to prove than
defamation battery is the intentional
harmful contact of one person against
another and Carol alleged that the
potential crimes that gave rise to the
battery included rape sexual abuse
sexual misconduct or forcible touching
now you might be wondering why a battery
that is more than 25 years old was being
heard in 2023 and the statute of
limitations to bring civil lawsuits over
sexual assault in New York is generally
three years and you know the statutes of
limitations exist for a good reason
after a sufficient out of time has
passed it can be hard for a defendant to
muster a defense
because evidence just disappears over
time and Witnesses lose their memory but
here in 2022 New York passed the adult
survivors act which opened a one-year
window from November 24th 2022 to
November 24th 2023 for people to sue
their alleged assailants even if the
statute of limitations had expired and
Carol filed her lawsuit within minutes
of the law taking effect on November
24th 2022. now despite some dubious
motion practice from Joe takapina
Trump's lawyer he actually received some
praise from the judge for his skill in
the courtroom but unfortunately for him
he had Donald Trump as a client and
Trump boxed himself into a corner
regarding his defense by claiming that
each and Carroll made everything up it
allowed the plaintiff to easily refute
that particular defense Trump claimed
that he had never met Carol and she
wasn't his type so the evidence that
they had met despite being tenuous was
bad for Trump and the same with his
deposition testimony that he confused
her with his ex-wife Marla Maples and
the plaintiffs jumped on that and the
videotaped footage of Donald Trump's
deposition was fairly devastating
I don't even know who the woman let's
say I don't know who it's Marla
you say marbles in the photo that's
Marla yeah that's that's my wife which
one woman are you pointing each other
now here
oh [__] the person you just pointed to
me
by the way it was completely
inappropriate for Trump's lawyer Elena
Haba to jump into the deposition and
Coach the witness and suggest the right
answer after Trump's fumble now the
legal maneuvering was continuing
throughout trial for example Joe
takapina told the judge that Trump was
not going to testify however at the same
time the takapina was resting the
defense's case Trump was telling a press
Gaggle in Ireland that he intended to
cut his trip short to confront Carol in
court he said quote I was falsely
accused by this woman I have no idea who
she is then judge Kaplan did some legal
maneuvering of his own and point blank
asked takapina whether Trump was waiving
his right to testify takapina said yes
then Judd Kaplan said quote how recently
have you spoken with him to which
takapina replied a few minutes before I
came into court this morning now judge
Kaplan probably knew what was coming
next where Trump would claim he wasn't
allowed to testify because the whole
system was corrupt especially the judge
so judge Kaplan bent over backwards to
make sure that he gave Trump every
opportunity to be heard so he told
takapina that his client had until 5 PM
on Sunday to file a motion to testify
but Trump to no one's surprise did not
return to New York and takapina did not
file such a motion and now we have the
verdict a federal jury in New York found
former president Trump liable for
defamation and assaulting Carroll in the
1990s the jury awarded Carroll five
million dollars in compensatory and
punitive damages after deliberating for
less than three hours which is not a lot
of time for a jury deliberation and when
a jury is deliberating the jurors review
the instructions on how to apply the law
and then answer questions on the verdict
form which we happen to have here here
the jury rejected the allegation that
the encounter between Carol and Trump
constituted rape you can see that the
question was number one on the verdict
form the jurors instead checked the Box
on the verdict form which was in the
alternative of sexual abuse that means
the jury believed Trump touched Carol
without her consent so while the jury
found that Carol met her burden
regarding sexual assault they apparently
did not find that she met her burden
that Trump had penetrated her which
would have been required for the rape
alexand so the jury awarded her two
million dollars in compensatory damages
for the abuse turning again to the
verdict form the jury concluded that
Trump had made a false statement and
that he made this false statement with
actual Mouse which was a high bar for
Carol to clear the jury awarded her 1
million dollars in Damages for
compensatory damages for the amount that
she actually lost effectively out of
pocket and an additional 1.7 million
dollars for damaging her reputation the
jury added 280 000 in punitive damages
and an extra twenty thousand dollars for
wanton disregard and in concluding judge
Kaplan advised the jurors to keep their
identity secret and not to publicly
identify the other jurors and although
it's legal for jurors to talk about
their experiences and identify
themselves to the media here the judge
had taken extraordinary precautions for
a civil case ruling that before trial
the jury would be anonymous due to the
threats that Trump and his supporters
have made against juries and prosecutors
in the past but now the Carol was
successful she'll probably want to
celebrate with a delicious home-cooked
meal which she can do with today's
sponsor hellofresh she doesn't even need
to spend 5 million dollars on it because
hellofresh is a great way to eat
delicious fresh food while still being
healthy it's a great way to get back
into a diet or just eat great food in
fact hello fresh has a whole variety of
calorie smart carbs or pescatarian and
veggie options and you can customize it
how you want to hello fresh delivers
fresh quality produce from the farm to
your door in less than a week and this
may hell fresh to celebrating Asian
American and Pacific Islander heritage
month so you can try limited time
authentic recipes created in partnership
with Chef serbisani of New York City's
tag Mo restaurant and enjoy a cultural
taste tour right in your own kitchen now
I'm a do-it-yourself person and I have
to say I was initially pretty skeptical
about hellofresh because I think I'm a
pretty good cook and I didn't really
need the help but I actually loved it
even for an experienced cook hellofresh
delivers new ingredients and recipes
that I'd never try on my own and of
course everything was delivered straight
to my door so I didn't have to do any
shopping the produce actually gets to
you faster than a grocery store so it
arrives at Peak freshness and flavor and
it's also super easy to save time
hellofresh cuts out meal planning and
prep so the recipes only take 20 to 30
minutes to cook which is literally less
time to cook than it would normally take
to do shopping and hellofresh is
actually cheaper than grocery shopping
and at least 25 cheaper than takeout so
if you'd like to try hello fresh go to
hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle16 for 16 free meals plus free
shipping yes you can actually get 16
free meals plus free shipping by click
on the link that's on screen right now
or down in the description so click on
the link below and use the code legal
eagle 16. and after that click on this
playlist over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court